[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's david cohn former yankee champ now
a yankee announcer on the yes network as
aaron judge has hit his 60th home run
and uh david cohen back on the program
good to see you david if you were
pitching last night in the ninth inning
when aaron judge came to the plate
would you have gone at him
or avoided
in that situation i would have gone at
him i thought will crow did the right
thing you had a four run lead
you know aaron judge at that point it
was a 3-1 count
yeah yeah i would have challenged him
you know i pitched in cal ripken's last
game at camden yards and i threw him
nothing but fastballs the whole night i
tried to challenge him it was kind of
the honor system i knew it was his fair
you know i i respected him so much so
i've actually been in that situation
before and i did exactly what will crow
did last night
i i admire that you know that you felt
like hey this is the last time we're
gonna see cal
and i if he hits if he takes me deep you
were fine with that
i was fine with it it was a meaningless
game
and it was his last game and
that had such enormous respect for how
he went about it and i think that's part
of the reason why you see
opposing pitchers respect aaron judge so
much because the way he acts the way he
carries himself he hit the 60th home run
set his back down quietly ran around the
bases as if it was like any other home
run and i think that really resonates
with opposing pitchers and i've heard
that around the league about how much
respect that aaron judge garners because
just the way he carries himself similar
to the way cal ripken carried himself
how would you pitch to aaron judge
he has really changed dan this year i
mean he's really made great improvements
on not chasing as many breaking balls
you know you used to try to get him to
chase sliders off the plate right and
left one after another eventually you'd
get him to chase he's not doing that
anymore when guys stop chasing fastballs
and slow stuff away then they're usually
susceptible with fastballs up and in
he's hitting those pitches as well uh
this year so
there's really no one place to go and
get him out this year i think that's why
he's on on the verge of a triple crown
uh in the american league this year yeah
and i think that's important you know
his batting eye and he's he's 30 years
of age so that that to me is what's
interesting that he is making himself
better learning to be a better player at
age 30. that doesn't normally happen at
that age
no he doesn't you know he's got a setup
he's got sort of his own program his own
hitting style his own swing that he owns
but he also has uh these high-speed
pitching machines at yankee stadium and
the bows of the stadium if you walk
through the bowels of yankee stadium
you'll see a pitching sort of a batting
cage set up for aaron judge and it's a
high-speed pitching machine that throws
a hundred mile an hour sliders it can
make it it can make it break at that
high velocity and he'll he'll go up
there in between innings and he'll just
track really fast sliders high spin
sliders and he's trained his eye to sort
of see that so that when he's in the
game and he sees a 90 mile an hour
slider
it's like taking the donut off the bat
you know it's like oh yeah i track it i
see it now
uh who do you consider the single season
home run champ
uh wow you know
there's an asterisk it's still barry
bonds but you have to put an asterisk
around the steroid era you know i'm not
saying we don't acknowledge them uh i'm
not trying to be judgmental in the
holier than thou with my attitude but i
do think we need to acknowledge the
elephant in the room that uh you know
these guys probably were enhanced they
probably did use performance-enhancing
drugs even though you know we don't have
definitive proof we certainly know
pretty well you know the very bonds did
and mark maguire did so
yeah you have to put an asterisk around
that era so who is the real one that's a
great debate that's what makes this so
interesting that you know a lot of
people think it's right now what aaron
judge is doing is the real home run
chase and aaron judge himself who grew
up in the san francisco area still
credits barry bonds he said i was a kid
watching barry bonds flip him into the
into the uh to the bay at san francisco
so you know he he considers barry bonds
the real home run champ so yeah that's
what makes baseball so great we can
debate these generational type things
more than any other sport yeah but i
didn't have to be on the mound facing
these guys you did
but what's that like knowing
that that guy
in my mind is using performance
enhancing drugs and you have to pitch to
them
it was the lines were blurred back then
in the 90s i mean with the benefit of
hindsight now i can look back and say
hey wait a minute you know i want my
pitching numbers adjusted i pitched in a
different era here wait my era was
better than it really really was well
that's why i look at what pedro martinez
did coney i mean pedro
was i mean that's in the american league
in the steroid era in the heart of it
and pedro is dealing
that's exactly right that's you know
that's just sort of you know in baseball
we have these advanced metrics that have
these adjusted stats ops plus er er a
plus that factors in the environment
that you played in the league averages
well you're right pedro martinez could
be the greatest pitcher ever because of
what he had to deal with in that era and
aaron judge could be having the greatest
season ever because he's played in an
integrated era he's playing in an era
that the you know we do test for
steroids he's playing in an era where
offense is down across the board he's
got 20 more home runs than the next guy
he's completely lapped the fields but
that's what i don't know
david is in today's analytics
everybody's trying to hit home runs
you're throwing as hard as you can and
i'm swinging as hard as i can
why are home runs down
uh well i think partly as the baseball
major league baseball has talked about
changing the baseball they're certainly
you know major league baseball owns
rawlings who makes the baseballs they
they're on record as saying they're
trying to make the baseball more uniform
the the theory among pitchers in the
major leagues is that there's two
different baseballs there's one that
flies and there's one that dies this
year they're using the one that dies
more is what they say so and major
league baseball's on record this isn't
this isn't me breaking any new news that
they're trying to make the baseball
travel less trying to get more action
into the game i think they i think
they're trying to have a uniform
baseball that gets away from exactly
what you're saying where it's just a
home run game we want more contact we
want more action that's why the rules
are changing next year with the pitch
clock yada yada that's that's the theory
behind a lot of these changes
i wonder if pitchers pitch to bonds
when he hit 73
if he would have hit 100 home runs that
year dude
it's a valid question dan it really is
because you look at how many times 100
yeah i think what 200 times he was
walked that year or one at 180 at least
180 paulie says yeah and yeah 180 and a
lot of those were intentional a lot were
unintentional buck showalter walked up
with the bases blown in one game i mean
you know they go with four four yeah
we'll we'll suck up that run and you go
take first base i mean that's not
ridiculous it became with bonds
oh my god did you face bonds in that era
i faced him when he was in pittsburgh
when i was on in the national league so
and then we in 1992 we both were free
agents and he went to san francisco i
went to kansas city so that was kind of
the last time i saw him was was his
pittsburgh days the first six years of
his career i wonder about you mentioned
judge growing up in the bay area
he turned down the deal with the yankees
but didn't even counter that offer i
think by the yankees
how much concern do you think there is
with the yankees that maybe aaron judge
does want to play someplace else maybe
he does want to play in san francisco
we just don't know i mean aaron judge
has played this so close to the vest you
know dan we were in boston recently and
somebody asked him about boston and he
said oh what great fans you know in
boston what a great place to play i mean
it's like he has the script and he's
playing the poker where nobody could
read him he has no tells
we don't know what he really thinks we
don't know how important his home is to
him where he grew up we don't even know
if the giants are going to be in play
even though we think they might be if
they're going to spend that kind of
money yeah so yeah i mean he's got one
shot at this aaron judge is 30 years old
he's got one shot at being a free agent
and actually finding out what other
offers will be and i think he's so close
that's what he wants to get to he wants
to find out is there another owner out
there is there a couple of owners out
there that are going to really push the
system and he that's the only true way
you can find out what your market value
is but i wonder about that
pujols was 31 when the cardinals let him
go they got a hall of fame career from
pujols
and it was the right decision judge is
going to be 31 starting this next season
would you sign him to a 10-year deal
well yeah you know that here is here's
where the rubber beats the road the
reason there are 10-year deals out there
is because the owners themselves want to
spread out those costs because of the
luxury tax they could theoretically pay
aaron judge what he's worth what is the
top of the payroll right now max
scherzer makes in the mid 40s okay give
aaron judge a six year deal then for 50
million a year rather than try to do the
10-year deal for 35 or 40 million a year
it's the owners who want to spread out
those costs and avoid the luxury tax so
you know it's hard to blame the players
for that it's hard to say well we can't
give him 10 years because he'll be 38
well you don't have to you could pay him
top dollar or go way above and beyond
for five years and pay him more than
anybody else in the history of the game
because he's doing something else that
nobody else in the history of the game
is doing this year so he certainly
proved his worth we're talking to david
cohn he is uh announcer for the yankees
on the s network and of course a uh
former great pitcher world series champ
why didn't the yankees bunt on curt
schilling in game six no4 come on i
heard you say that before it is
it is so good that you say that and it's
it brought back the memories to me of
watching that series and thinking the
same exact damn thing you know it's like
you had to test him didn't you i mean
certainly uh it shows you dan that
people don't know how to bond anymore
it's a lost art probably the best the
last best great bunner i saw was brett
butler
the great lead-off hitter for the
dodgers and the and and the braves at
one point he could do it with the best
of them wait till the last minute
disguise it laid down a bunt guys just
don't know how to bun anymore for the
last 20 years really oh my god
you faced gwen a few times right
yes many times
what's that i remember talking to maddox
he said you know i got to the point
where
i i didn't know how to
what to throw to him because it felt
like he knew what whatever i was
throwing i was going to be around the
plate he was going to do something with
it
like they don't have batting eyes like
that and you don't get paid
to hit for you know 360 370.
i mean
do you think we're ever getting back to
that where you know you got boggs and
you know kuru and ichiro and these guys
brett that it meant something to bat
that hive because the analytics that you
know they're not going to favor you when
it comes to making money
yeah i think you're it's a you're dead
on once again uh you know the ironic
part is theo epstein who's one of the
most progressive thinkers in the last 20
years
is now out of baseball or in on the the
management side trying to sort of
disassemble everything he created and
create new rules to kind of get more
action in the game exactly to the heart
of the matter of what you're talking
about we need more contact we need more
action we need more base running we need
more doubles and triples we need uh
something to happen sooner in baseball
games there's four minutes between a
ball put in a play now compared to two
minutes uh 30 years ago so you know
that's really what's going on in major
league baseball now trying to address
exactly what you're talking about uh
tony gwynn was unreal you know the joke
among pitchers was you know what you
have to do to him just throw it down the
middle because he doesn't know what to
do with the pitch down in the middle you
throw it in he hits a line drive to
right you throw it away it's a line
drive to the left so just throw it down
the middle of the first pitch and see
see if he confuses himself are the
dodgers an all-time great team
this season they have a chance to be
they have a chance to be the greatest
team in dodgers history and then also to
get into the argument of all time
greatest teams we don't know how many
games are going to end up winning if
they get to the 1
10 to 120 area maybe 140 we had 114 in
1998 and we closed the deal and won the
world series a couple years later the
seattle mariners won 116 games in the
regular season ichiro's first year but
they didn't close the deal and nobody
talks about that so yes if they close
the deal they have their signature
moment they're kind of in the middle of
a little dynasty right now the dodgers
and this could be their 1998 yankees
year
the one that really is their signature
point in time the great one of the
greatest teams in franchise history i
think the dodgers could easily do that
they're having a signature year not only
in the history of baseball but for that
organization it's the dodgers going back
to brooklyn yeah this could be the
greatest dodgers team of all time if
they can close it out where are your
world series rings
i have them in storage actually you know
i'm afraid to break them out i'm going
to leave it in a hotel room one night
you know yeah i'm a little bit of an
airhead that way you know i tend to
forget things and
leave leave things that sitting on hotel
rooms you know and on the bed stand but
you got five of them don't you
i do i have five of them i have one with
the blue jays in 92 which they just uh
you know was the 30-year anniversary up
in toronto for that one so that's the
beauty of these things and that's what i
told dave roberts recently the manager
of the dodgers i said do you
you understand you know you realize that
and he's going no i'm just trying to win
tonight and i said well you're going to
appreciate it later you know that you've
got your hands around the throat of
maybe one of the greatest seasons of all
time and it's going to mean a lot to you
on down the road 20 years from now
you're going to be really much more
appreciative of what's happening right
now and he said you know you're right i
need to to learn and stop and stop and
smell the roses but
there's so much anxiety in trying to win
today stay in the moment win tonight and
close the deal and don't blow it you
know that most most players are filled
with that kind of anxiety certainly
managers as well
you got a pitch that you still
that could wait wake you up in the
middle of the night like there's
something that you did and you want that
pitch back
yes there's a few of them ken griffey jr
hit a couple of upper deck rockets off
game five and what's that sound like
what's that sound like three at night
what's it sound like when when you give
up a home run of that magnitude oh
it's you know that's what wakes me up
it's a sound jim tomy hit an upper deck
rocket grand slam off of me in game six
of
the playoffs in the lcs one year at
yankee stadium and the sound was it was
scary i flinched on the mound it was so
loud it was like a gunshot
like only jim tomy could hit them and
and the old yankee stadium and the true
upper deck shots that were majestic
halfway up so yeah that's the sound i
remember off of jim tomy's bat my god uh
maddox told me it sounded like a car
crash whenever he and he always wanted
to give up a home run that went really
really far
he said i hate it if it just squeaked
over the wall if you hit it 316 that
made me mad if you hit a bomb
okay give me the ball let me go let me
get it not that maddox gave up you know
that many hormones is he the best
pitcher of all time
it feels like maddox is underrated it
feels like maddox is underrated dude
absolutely the the best combination of
movement and control that i've ever seen
the best craftsman of all time like you
know a guy who was
what do you weigh 165 pounds you know
yeah he's up there on the mound
never missed a start
never even had a probably a sore arm it
took the ball
over 700 games started in the big
leagues
as long as he pitched
just flipping little sinkers on the
black out there and just change up
slower than slow and just messing with
hitters and laughing and smirking on the
mound you betcha he was the best
craftsman of all time okay i'm gonna
you're the manager
game seven
any pitcher you want you can't pick you
and you were eight and three i think in
your career in the posting so who are
you sending out there
in the last 50 years
who's pitching game seven for you
randy johnson
because i think he just neutralizes
left-handed batters so much left-handed
batters remember john kroc turning
around hitting right-handed against him
in the all-star game paul o'neill for
the yankees wanted no part of randy
johnson so i think just that in and of
itself that if you're a left-handed
batter in any lineup and most great
lineups have pretty good left-handed
batters generally speaking randy johnson
just owns those guys so you can take
that part out of the equation he threw a
hundred miles an hour plus with a slider
that was a razor blade
buzz stall slider i'm taking randy
johnson great to mention he's 611 on the
mound and kind of ugly too he's kind of
scary-looking did you face him
i never faced him i mean i not i was in
the american league so i never got the
bat against him i certainly faced him
and watched him mow through our lineups
you know and that old kingdom too the
lighting wasn't good kind of fuzzy in
the kingdom
the that was the first time there's a
term called fuzz you're throwing fuzz
randy johnson threw fuzz the ball looked
like it had fuzz coming off it was
blurry because he threw so hard
i love randy johnson yeah throwing fuzz
that means you're throwing pretty hard
yes it's blurry but i don't did you
throw fuzz
not not like randy johnson no i was born
i was known for spin you know spinning
it dropping down changing arm angles i
tried to be like louis theon you know i
was 12 years old in 1970
in the world series and i fell in love
with louis tion pitching for the red sox
at fenway park and i was out in the
backyard after that after every game
playing wiffle ball trying to be louis
theon so that that was my guy i tried to
be like louie good to talk to you again
david thanks for joining us and uh enjoy
the ride there this season
my pleasure dan always good to be on
with you that's david cohn he won five
world series and uh he was uh
i forgot he was in toronto and uh
because toronto went back to back with
ceto gaston